I've been very like something's got to
be from the beginning of former New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg's
presidential campaign he bet on Super
Tuesday seeing it as an opportunity to
enter the race and scoop up a
substantial number of Delegates that
didn't pay off Bloomberg ended his bid
for president after winning only one
nominating contest in American Samoa I
entered the race for president to defeat
Donald Trump and today I am leaving the
race for the same reason to defeat
Donald Trump because staying in would
make it more difficult to achieve that
goal Tuesday's results setup what looks
to be more like a two-person race
between former Vice President Joe Biden
and senator Bernie Sanders but if you
were looking at your Facebook feed ahead
of Super Tuesday it probably didn't feel
that way Bloomberg spent at least 620
million dollars on building his campaign
and spreading his message before
dropping out about 75 million of that
went to digital where his social media
strategy was both unique and
controversial at the center of those
efforts was hawkfish a digital tech firm
Bloomberg owns it was set up not just
for him but to help Democrats generally
so Mike Bloomberg created hawkfish in
spring of 2019 and a lot of Bloomberg's
advisors really believed that Trump won
the 2016 election because of their very
strong digital effort so the firm's
primary focus was on digital advertising
on Facebook and Google Bloomberg grant
ads on issues such as climate change and
gun safety reform though most were
focused on attacking President Trump and
that's something that could outlast
Bloomberg's bid for president hawkfish
also experimented with new ways of
reaching younger voters there was this
meme of Bloomberg's face on a meatball
and this one that the Bloomberg campaign
paid a popular Instagram account to post
separately there was this doctored video
where Bloomberg asks I'm the only one
here I think the SEVIS started the
business is that fair and the other
candidates appear to fall silent so a
bunch of Democratic strategists and
others said that that video is
misinformation the Bloomberg campaign
said it was tongue-in-cheek
more controversial however was the
Bloomberg campaigns use of what it calls
deputy digital organizers in California
The Wall Street Journal reported the
campaign hired hundreds of workers to
post regularly on their personal social
media accounts in support of Bloomberg
and then send text messages to their
friends about him while it's totally
common for different political campaigns
to ask their supporters to spread the
message by word of mouth it's quite
unusual to pay thousands of dollars to
get that support then it gets into this
murky area of what the rules are so do
you have to disclose if you're paid for
writing a post yes generally you have to
and the Federal Trade Commission says
you have to for businesses but the
Federal Election Commission which
oversees campaign finance law does not
yet have a specific rule on that front a
lot of tech platforms like Facebook
which owns Instagram Google and Twitter
have tried to set their own rules for
political content but their policies
differ on when and exactly what a user
has to disclose we are in this ultra
digital social media infused climate and
a lot of the rules have not caught up to
the content now the question is will
Bloomberg keep spending against Trump
when ending his bid he endorsed by did
hawkfish is expected to keep working on
behalf of democrats hawkfish has done
work before that doesn't involve Mike
Bloomberg it worked on State Legislative
races in states like Kentucky and
Virginia so we think it's possible that
they could do that type of work again
and sources have said that they will
stay open throughout the general
election